am I pleased to say the shadow attorney
general Emily Thornbury joins us once
again and stood up very good morning
um can we start with that just did the
inflation figures out today when Jeremy
Hunt says you know his priority is
bringing down inflation my mind suggests
a link between uh what is happening
today and of course the the strike
action the the request from various
parts of the public sector for
significant increases to their pay I
think it makes it less likely that the
chancellor will be able to provide them
with money what is your view well I
think my view is is that um this is
welcome that the inflation rate is going
down but it's still the second worst
month that we've seen for 40 years
um you know inflation of over 10 percent
means obviously that people's wages are
being eaten into
um and and as we've heard you know food
prices are much higher than that so what
needs to happen is that we need to have
proper negotiation so I know I was I was
on your program a month ago I think you
know when there was the dispute
happening in relation to just the
railways at that point and I said my
concern was that the government
could be tempted to play games with this
and could be tempted to try and play it
to their political Advantage instead of
actually looking for a solution sure
sure what they should be doing but
living people around a round a table
yeah it should have been labor would no
more agree to what the rmt or indeed the
the Royal College of nurses are asking
than the conservatives would you know
that we would not be arriving at the
last minute if for example in the rmt
strike and be talking about about
driver-only trains you know at the last
minute when it looked like then maybe
there was a there was a solution finally
being found we would not be calling in
the RCN and saying to them do talk to us
nurses but let's not talk about pay I
mean we would not be doing that we would
be negotiating and we would be trying to
find a solution because a strike is a
failure a strike is a failure on both
sides both sides need to compromise and
you need people to sit around a table
and work out what the compromise is do
you detect that the public support for
for the strikes which on which Dr has
generally been you know in terms of the
public set and indeed in the railway
workers do you detect that that public
support is starting to to Wing slightly
no I don't I think that people see that
there needs to be a solution and I think
you know I think people are greatly
inconvenienced and and that makes people
upset and angry and disappointed that
they're not able to do what they hope so
I think that there's still there seems
to be you know support and let's let's
not forget we're not just talking about
the public sector I mean there are many
strikes in the privacy of course of
course when I was talking to one of the
bosses from mcvitty's where there was a
strike that was settled there was hardly
any publicity about it but the both the
employer and the unions took a pragmatic
View and they sorted it out but when it
comes to to the Health Service and very
specifically the nurses it is it is less
inconvenience and it is more than actual
damage may be done this morning we have
you know NHS England's cancer director
warning that urgent cancer surgery could
be canceled no no that is surely an
outcome that is not just unwanted it is
intolerable of course and and again
listening to what the nurses are saying
they're saying actually this is out of
date there were agreements this week in
the end both the employers and the
nurses want the same thing when it comes
to cancer patients emergency cases they
want to make sure that people are looked
after so it is just a question of of
sorting it out you know and and nurses
will not you turn away from somebody
who's a cancer patient or an emergency I
mean nobody believes that a nurse would
do that what they do want is they want
to have a decent pay settlement and they
want to have if they want to they want
to have more staff they want to not be
so overstretched they want to be
appreciated I wonder what you make if we
can turn our attention to immigration
that which we heard from from Rishi Suna
yesterday A Deal apparently being done
with with Albania I mean just just as a
point of principle if people are not
supposed to be here and they are
unsuccessful in an asylum claim labor
doesn't have a problem with them being
sent back to where they came from as
quickly as possible no what we think is
we should have an immigration system and
an asylum system which is fast and fair
yeah and firm we need to be able to get
decisions made about people and then if
they are refused they are refused and
they should be returned that's always
been our policy
Albania plan well
well I don't think you can have it have
a blanket you're from Albania therefore
you're going home because you know we
know that we need to look at individual
cases because you can't assume that this
woman has not been trafficked if she
says that she has you need to look at
that so you can't have blanket policies
but what you do need to do is you need
do you start making some decisions and
that's what they're not doing and then
you hear from the Prime Minister oh
we're going to make everything's going
to be fine we're going to double the
number of people in the backlog by the
end of next oh yeah and then you ask
what the backlog is and they're talking
about the backloggers just being before
June this year you think that's right
probably well so I mean think about it
right the backlog is just from June last
year right the bits before that so we're
going to have from June and then they're
going to take a year to clear it they
say so let's be generous and say that's
true that would mean by the end of next
year will be 18 months behind anyway do
you see I do I mean it's like it's all
you have to do when they when they say
these things is go well that sounds good
how's that going to work and it falls to
pieces can I ask you to pop your
lawyer's hat on for a second okay of
course the the story they did has been
discussing this morning the the idea
that the UK is now helping Ukrainian
judges train up for for dealing with the
well the war crimes that have been
taking place within their borders I mean
what specifically will they be being
obviously first and foremost do you
appreciate the plan but what is it that
you think that these judges can gain
from this yeah so I think it's great I
think it's really important
um and uh and and you know this
initiative has our full support I've
been I've been out to the Hague and I've
been in discussions about this there's a
number of things that can be done so
first of all there are cases that can be
done in terms of absolutely at the
Grassroots so if a soldier shoots a
civilian for no reason they should be
arrested and they should be tried
straight away and the and and the
additional training that's being given
to judges in Ukraine is great because
those cases need to absolutely stand up
but then you need to go further up the
chain and you need to look at the
generals and you need to look at those
responsible and you need in fact to be
able to reach right up to Putin because
Putin is in the end the person who sent
them in and he's the one who has agreed
to these bombing campaigns against
civilians and the whole aggression is
his responsibility so it is a question
of of making sure that the International
Community comes up with solutions that
will work together in order to hold the
Russians to account for the appalling
things they've been doing in Ukraine
Emily Thornbury great Italian in the
studio thanks very much